Let's look right now at the analysis of the algorithm.
What's the running time of Dijkstra in terms of the number of nodes (n)
and edges (m) when heaps are used?
The kinds of heaps we've been talking about to be able to find
the shortest distance so far so we can lock that down and run.
Here's the sketch of the algorithm again.
For each node, you find the shortest distance so far.
Remove it from the set because that one's now done
and we actually know the distance to that node.
Then we check each of its neighbors possibly reducing the distance
which wasn't a really big deal before, but it actually matters in the heap of limitation
because once we reduced the value associated with the node,
it needs to maybe be some place different in the heap.
In your implementation, the thing you're going to have to really watch out for is
making sure that when you update the value of the neighbor, you can find it in the heap.
Update the heap so the heap property is restored
and all of this information is communicated back and forth.
All right, let's imagine that we can do that and in fact,
reducing the distance of a value turns out to be, you can use up-heapify to do that
because the value, here let me draw.
If we have some value in the heap and we know that the heap property is satisfied
and what does that mean? That means that this node has to have a bigger value
or no smaller value than it's parent and it has to, itself, be smaller than both of its children.
Let's take a closer look at the issues that arise in a heap if one of the values,
let's say, we have this one, is suddenly reduced.
They get smaller, so let's just use a concrete example. The heap property is satisfied.
That means that whatever value this guy has, let's say it's 10,
have to be smaller than both of it's children but bigger or no smaller than it's parent.
What can happen if this node has its value reduced?
Well, let's take it to reduce a lot. Let's take it's reduced all the way to 1.
The heap property is no longer necessarily satisfied. It's actually fine from this node down.
This is fine. The problem is that this node, to it's parent, might no longer satisfy the heap property.
But the good news is, we talked about an operation that fixes exactly this problem.
If this is node (I). If we run up-heapify on this heap with a pointer to (I),
what it's going to do is bubble this small value up as high as it needs to be in the tree.
It's going to take Θ(log n) time and then the heap property will be restored and all will be well.
That's actually not a big problem unless you already have implemented.
The thing that makes this tricky is when you're talking about
some particular node, let's say, node (R).
You need to be able to find out very quickly the constant time where node (R) is in the heap
and as things get moved around in the heap, we have to keep that information updated.
That's really just that bookkeeping is actually the main thing that makes this challenging.
But let's take a look at the running time given that we can do this
distance reduction operation in logarithmic time.
For each node, we find the shortest distance and then for each node and each of its neighbors,
that is to say for each edge, we possibly reduce it's distance of a node.
What does that give us for a running time for this entire algorithm?
I want you to think it through and when you think you understand what the running time is,
find it in this list and check it off.